a way to try out robotic process
automation for free
palantir for ibm cloud pack for data and
improvements to your email and
notifications experience
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
to kick things off today how about i
give you a way to play with robots
for free we're excited to announce the
availability of a free
30-day trial of ibm robotic process
automation
or rpa rpa is predicted to remain one of
the fastest growing software segments
and this is your chance to explore this
technology and see how it can automate
work
and solve business problems with the
trial you'll get to use cutting edge rpa
features
like intelligent virtual agents
concurrent execution
and an integration with ibm cloud pack
for business automation
and that's not all you'll get for the
low low price of free
by signing up for the trial you'll also
get access to the ibm rpa academy
entry into automation recipes which is
our interactive rpa web training series
an eligibility to participate in a half
day workshop to learn how rpa can drive
high impact initiatives it's a pretty
good deal overall i'd say
to learn more about rpa technology and
register for the trial
see the link i've got in the description
of this video
next up let's take a look at palantir
for ibm cloud pack for data
data driven operational decisions are
critical for any organization
and palantir and ibm have partnered to
help solve these challenges for
organizations
and accelerate their use of ai in
business
palantir for ibm cloud pack for data
will help enable you to curate data
across a hybrid cloud environment into
palantir applications
then you can use watson models to
improve predictions with fairness and
accuracy
let's quickly look at five things this
service is designed to do
number one deliver ai for business
capabilities
in an easy to deploy and manage no code
or low code environment
number two simplify how data and ai
models are connected
to business decisions and actions number
three
inform better decisions by automatically
mapping data to industry context and
business value
number four automate how data is
collected organized and analyzed
across hybrid cloud data estates and
number five
consume services from a broad ecosystem
of data and ai capabilities
including ibm watson to learn more about
all the exciting opportunities available
with palantir for ibm cloud pack for
data
check out the link below to wrap things
up today i want to tell you about a
number of new enhancements to your email
and notifications experience
start with the biggest one the ui for
managing your notification preferences
has been completely redesigned
your preferences for receiving platform
notifications are organized separately
from the preferences you can set for
resource related ones
we have also improved our email designs
dramatically your announcements will now
be delivered using brand new email
designs that are optimized to give you
relevant information quickly
additionally there's new updates
behavior we have the ability to receive
a single email per incident or event
and then subscribe for updates from that
email's footer if you think they're
relevant
finally you can now also subscribe to
get updates about ongoing events
directly from your status page for a
closer look at these new enhancements
hit the link i've got below thanks so
much for joining me today for this
episode of ibm cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you